nature walks the discovery crucial
missing link in the ancestry of the
cetaceans porpoises dolphins and whales
ever since the time of Darwin scientists
have known that whales were descended
from land mammals but until very
recently about 15 years ago the
ancestors of whales were not known and
creationists had a field day because
there were no intermediates in the last
15 years then a number of remarkable
transitional forms have been found that
document the transition and the
morphology of these early whales very
nicely one such form is sketchy Cedars
could she see this is about 45 million
years old and as you see from the
skeleton it had a long tail and
relatively short legs it was an animal
well adapted to swim in water before
could she see this lift ambulocetus a
mule see this is about 49 million years
old and it lived in nearshore marine
teas in pakistan it's habit will
probably sort of like a crocodile and
then discovered most recently in 2001 is
the skeleton of pakicetus the first
known whale which didn't look anything
like a whale it really looked like a
wolf or so if you would see it in a zoo
however we know that this was already an
aquatic animal because of the structure
of it bones they are very dense this was
probably an animal that was waiting in
shallow water it was not a swimmer what
was missing at this point was the link
to the land relatives of whales and with
a new nature paper we think we have
found it and that link is in the highest
which I have been studying with mark
Clements Sunil bajpai B and Tre and Lisa
Cooper so just where in the fossil
record does this newly discovered
species fit the fossils are found in
Kashmir close to the Pakistani border
which is a difficult state to work so
the Indian scientists that we worked
with as a net
elected the newer fossils and they went
back to their site and collected some
more fossils they were collected as
blocks of rocks the blocks have been
marked with the locations of fossils but
it can take years of careful work to
extract and identify the most
significant bones the secrets of India
highest only just now being revealed
more than 15 years after the fossils
were collected I think the most exciting
moment came when my technician was
preparing the skull and he by accident
broke the ear off and he was ready to
glue it back and he showed it to me and
I realized that on the broken surface of
this ear you could see that the inside
of the bone was very thick just like
whale and not like any other land mammal
my contribution to this study was to
actually look at the bone structure
specifically of the bones of the limbs
and when we look at the bones of endo
hiatus in general they look just like a
regular terrestrial mammal mammal that
was walking on land but when we look at
the thicknesses of the bones that's when
the whole story changes the bones of
endo highest were actually extremely
thick this is the kind of thing that we
see in animals like hippopotamus that
live almost entirely in the water
although they can walk on land their
skeleton has change that allows them to
basically walk on the bottom of a river
bottom so what we do with endo hiatus is
we actually section the bones and then
mount them on slides and we grind them
down until we can see light through them
and what that'll show us is something
like this here you can see in a fossil
of an animal that was actually living on
land that was basically a small deer you
can see that the the bone layer is very
thin here but when we look at into
highest you can see that the bone is
actually very thick compared to the
inner medullary cavity or the bone
marrow and that indicates that endo
highest was in fact aquatic or wading in
water we can also take these slides and
put them through different polarizing
filters and that's what will give us a
really beautiful image - all this
evidence mark Clements of the University
of Wyoming has added an analysis of both
oxygen and carbon isotopes
the teeth of in Ohio's providing further
evidence of the amphibious life of this
animal so the new species in doe Hayase
helps bridge a 10 millennia gap in the
fossil record and hence tourism has
further studies to do he's exploring the
balance mechanisms in the ears of each
species many of these early whales have
very small organs of balance which is
sort of counterintuitive because you
would imagine that a whale who lives in
a very three-dimensional environment has
very good balancing organs but they
don't and we've looked at this in a
number of early whales and we know that
that changes very early in whale
evolution into highs as an animal that
we haven't studied with regard to this
and that's one thing that we definitely
want to do to as a graduate student it's
a tremendous opportunity to be able to
work on a project of this caliber
because not only am i learning the
techniques of being a good scientist
from hans but also the discovery of this
fossil is tremendous and one of the one
of my great passions in life is to study
the evolution of cetaceans and whales
dolphins and porpoises and it's been
just a thrilling fine to be able to
understand more of cetacean evolution
and the fact that we found that endo
highest was aquatic is is a profound and
amazing realization that it casts the
evolution of cetaceans in a whole new
light and so to actually be part of this
kind of finding is really gratifying
you